good morning believe nation today's
message is be patient over to you Kevin
direct it was kind of tough knowing that
sometimes I work so hard and everybody
else and I wasn't saying I wasn't
reaping the benefits of it and I wasn't
I wasn't getting any better as quickly
as I wanted to but I stayed patient and
that was one big thing for me is knowing
when to stay patient that everything is
gonna come around and I think that uh
you know with that patience I gained as
a kid it's helping me in the NBA right
now so you know for me is just you know
always always working hard and always
trying to get better and knowing that I
can get better knowing it you know I
didn't get to and I'm not there where I
want to be yet so I have a long ways to
go I think one of the hardest things
that entrepreneurs have to go through is
you feel like you're able to be up here
you have the taste to be here you know
what looks good at this level but you're
down here and you don't know how to
bridge that gap and every time you try
something it's just not good enough it's
not to the standards that you want to be
producing at I see this a lot with
people who are certainly a youtube
channel they look at somebody else's
youtube channel maybe they look at mine
and look at somebody else that they look
up to and say well I can do that I can
be like that person I can make a video I
can make it just as good and then they
create it and either it's not as good or
they don't get the results right like
they think it's okay but when they put
it up nobody's commenting no was doing
it nobody cares about what they put up
and that sucks and it really is hard to
compare yourself to where you are to
somebody else's middle you know when I
started doing speaking I would look at
guys like Tony Robbins I look at guys
like Les Brown and I still love Les
Brown I would look at his speeches and
say man I want to be like that where I
don't be able to speak with that emotion
to that level and you know look at or
what it's producing like I'm nowhere
close
like I'm nowhere close and every time I
tried to be nowhere close to where
les was that and that was frustrating
and a lot of people they quit at that
point like people say well I can't be
like les and so I'm done we're really
what you want to do is just compare
yourself to where you were yesterday are
you better than where you were yesterday
or if you are consistent are you better
than where you were last week or last
month or last year because if you
continue to hone your craft you'll get
better it's unfair for me who is just
getting started as a speaker to compare
myself to one of the most legendary
speakers of all time it's a good
aspirational goal having those people to
look up to it can be helpful can be a
milestone can be a direction but it can
also be harmful and that you expect to
get there too quickly and when it
doesn't quickly match up when you're not
there fast enough you get frustrated you
get the breast you get down you think
it's never gonna work and so it's unfair
for me at the start of my career to look
at Les Brown one of the greatest of all
time you know at the middle slash end of
his career where really what I should
have been doing is looking at hey did I
make improvements and so for your own
business for your own growth whatever
you're trying to learn whatever you're
trying to get better at I encourage you
to look back look back in the work you
made last week last month last year is
it better now than what you did before
and if you continue to hone your craft
you continue to beat on it you continue
to get better and better and better
Keith put more effort in your work will
improve and eventually you will close
that gap
so the question today today is are you
patient enough with your growth and
development I'm curious to find out
leaving the comments below and I will
join the discussion thank you so much
for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of espresso